as questions sorry 12 o'clock let's um
we're going to speak now i think to the
new deputy prime minister and secretary
of state for health and social care that
is to raise coffee uh teres coffee good
morning to you thank you very much for
being with us what's going to be a very
busy day for you and the government um
first of all let's just let's just talk
about the fact that liz trust has now
been appointed as prime minister um
what kind of vision do you think she'll
be able to bring to the country
well the prime minister set out a very
clear vision yesterday on the doorsteps
of downing street uh focusing on the
economy in terms of growing the economy
in terms of uh tackling energy both
what we will do to help households and
businesses but the longer term of energy
supply and indeed the nhs and that's why
i've been honoured to be uh
appointed as secretary of state for
health and social care
and i'm looking forward to working on
what i'm calling my abcd ambulances
backlogs care doctors and dentists
because ultimately this is about
patients getting the treatment and the
appointments they need to make sure that
they continue to get better
now i'm not going to ask you endlessly
about the huge uh package of help and
support the households and businesses
that is coming
only to to ask you is it coming and will
it be around about the range that we
have been reported about 130 billion
pounds
well clearly we've just been through a
significant leadership campaign but i
know liz uh being the serious person
that she is and recognising that we need
to hit the ground running we have been
working on plans as potential
what we could do
recognizing that in less than 24 hours
we've still certainly working to make
sure we finalise the details of plans on
each of the points that we've set out
and i know that this week as the prime
minister
said yesterday there will be a further
announcement
and i'm sure that that will assure
people
indeed when they hear what is going to
be offered i certainly will reassure
people they've been waiting quite a
while to hear something and and you
contradict yourself a little bit with
them and miss cough you said 24 hours
then you said this week so is it
thursday or friday we're going to
finally hear the plan
well the prime minister's been in place
for less than 24 hours is what i was
referring to
and indeed this government
being appointed um not only the cabinet
last night as i'll be heading to downing
street a bit later uh but indeed uh the
new government this week yes the
intention is that there will be uh
proposals set out
to parliament in the country uh this
week on what we are going to do about
energy
and the big question of course then will
be
something is going to be done it's going
to be a large amount of money spent and
how is that going to be paid for
because this trust of course wants to
cut taxes
well what we want to do is to grow the
economy and at the moment we have a high
tax burden uh we are making sure that we
want to focus on that by mixture of both
kind of encouraging investment rather
than putting up corporation tax uh but
also uh making sure that we on our
manifesto commitment to the people that
voted for our party in 2019 and that's
why we'll be reversing the national
insurance levy but indeed we just need
to continue to focus on the supply side
reform so making it easier to do
business making it easier to run
government in order to make sure that
the main focus is on the outcomes that
we deliver for people in this country
and to make sure we do that as
effectively and efficiently as possible
i mean how challenging is it going to be
for you going into that brief of
health and social care to have that levy
being reversed that was going to be a
lot of money that those services in the
nhs and social care were really waiting
for
well the intention is that will be
funded from general taxation
and that is the case so we will continue
to invest the same amount
into health and social care that we
would setting out through the levy but i
think it's important that we
make sure we now get into the detail of
how we are going to make improvements
for patients to access
ambulances or their doctors or dentists
indeed many other aspects of primary
care that's needed in order to i say
keep people um healthy
so general taxation to pay for health
and social care but of course is it
going to be general taxation is going to
pay for this um package of measures to
help households with their energy bills
or is that going to be borrowing
well we'll be going through that i mean
uh ultimately uh
we receive money through taxation from
uh from from people and businesses uh
and then redistribute that accordingly
to the priorities uh set out in our
manifesto and the needs of the country
so uh more will be said about that uh
aspects of that uh in during this week
i mean you're suggesting that you could
fund this through taxation that's not
the case that was it because this trust
is is not gonna fund this huge amount of
money that's gonna be spent through
taxation and it wouldn't get anywhere
near the amounts that are needed
well this is how the government receives
money from um
from people and businesses is through
general taxation and variety of ways
but it's important that we continue to
focus on honoring our manifesto in 2019
that's what the prime minister also said
uh on the doorstep of downing street and
that's what we intend to do
i'm conscious that we
have a lot to still achieve but we
should recognise that for example in the
nhs that there's more people working in
the nhs than ever before but also
recognize that there are still vacancies
too so we need to continue to get a grip
of
what is happening locally and i'm
looking forward to that challenge
i mean you forgive me for saying this
coffee but everyone knows that the
government receives money through
general taxation what they're wondering
is when they need help with energy bills
when businesses are going out of
business because they can't afford to
pay their energy they need help from the
government and where is that money going
to come from are you going to borrow it
well i've explained to you that with the
aspects of energy um what we're going to
do about that will be set out uh during
this week
and you people including you will just
have to wait for the detail of that
i will be waiting patiently miss coffee
i do appreciate we are going to find out
eventually i i'm sure uh let's just move
on to the reshuffle uh that we saw
yesterday of course that you got uh the
job of health and social care um but we
did see um
johnny mercer sacked from being veterans
minister and you will have seen i i
think perhaps the tweet posted on social
media by his wife covering that
very very upset
describing the person who sacked him at
liz trust as an imbecile
well i'm very conscious that uh liz has
appointed a really diverse cabinet i'm
delighted that james heapey minister for
the armed forces and now also minister
for veterans will be taking on that role
and will be attending cabinet this
morning
this is i think a government of
of all the talents that we have in this
party and i know that the prime minister
is very focused on delivery uh focused
on pace and that is what we will be
aiming to achieve including for our
armed forces and indeed our veterans
i mean it but it's not diverse is it
when all the supporters of rishi sunaik
have been sacked and removed from their
posts
um i'm very conscious that during the
contest uh the majority of people in
cabinet supported liz trust to become
prime minister liz is now the prime
minister she's appointed i think a
really diverse cabinet and we will be
focused on delivery and i'm excited
about the opportunity to be part of that
i mean you have no concerns then that
just by appointing allies and supporters
she might well be alienating people
we've seen uh the um the shade being
thrown by johnny mercer's wife we've
seen some other sort of slightly
critical comments by people who've been
removed from jobs and haven't got the
jobs that they wanted are you confident
that the party can come back together
it's just always the talk throughout the
leadership contest that after the
bitterness the party would have to come
back together and govern
um
liz has appointed a cabinet of a mixture
of whether it's people of her
proactive supporters people who did not
support her as well this isn't she isn't
focused on about people who support her
or not she's focused on about a
government of all the talents the rest
of the government uh will continue to be
appointed during today and i think that
uh people will be able to see that we
will continue to focus and have a broad
church of people in our government and
i'm very conscious that the conservative
party
one of the greatest parties on earth
will continue to be united and to make
sure that we really turn our focus on
delivery of our manifesto delivery
against the challenges that we face
today right now and indeed making sure
that we are also concerned sufficiently
to make sure that we are focused on the
next general election too
so just a convenient coincidence that
all the people that support it are the
most talented ones for the jobs
i'm very conscious that many existing
members of the cabinet
have been reappointed into roles and
privileged to do that and to work
alongside our prime minister
with the plans that we have set forward
and you know obviously we're going to
get all the details in in the coming
days as you say um what we'll have to to
give because there obviously isn't a
magic money tree uh
the country is facing an economic
squeeze so what priorities do you think
of the government will have to give
well as the premises set out during uh
the campaign her significant focus is
about growing the economy we can't just
have a managed decline that won't help
anybody and that is why in terms of
getting growth going really matters both
uh in terms of making sure that we focus
on making it easier to do business and
that is why i'm really excited by the
appointments that we have
in the chancellor in business in trade
but this is a cross-government effort
and we will continue to make sure that
we do strain every sinew pull every
lever that we can in order to get our
economy growing again
as i say we cannot just look forward to
manage decline and liz has got i think
the bold economic plan to make sure that
we can get on and deliver that
nobody said this is going to be easy
we're conscious that around the world we
have an inflationary challenge
i'm conscious that we will continue to
keep our commitments uh to honor and to
continue to support ukraine as they are
part of this uh unnecessary aggressive
act of um war by putin on ukraine so
there's a number of challenges of course
that this government is facing today
we're not alone in that in terms of uh
global issues but we am determined sorry
i'm determined that we will support the
prime minister and we will on the plan
that she's setting out in order to make
sure that we can grow the economy that
we fix the energy challenge and that we
make sure that we uh tackle the backlogs
and also access to primary care
now of course i appreciate of your time
this morning race coffee but just a
couple more questions if you if you will
um
about abortion there have been concerns
raised about your
voting record about abortion and do you
personally support it
um i'm conscious i have voted against
abortion laws
what i will say is i'm the complete
democrat and that is done
so it's not that i'm seeking to undo
any um any aspects of abortion laws
yeah i mean just and just to follow up
on that then i mean
women up and down the country people up
and down the country we should be
wanting to know exactly where you stand
on the issue because uh if you're not
entirely supportive of it there will be
some concern and some concerns have been
raised by some support groups for people
who have abortions
well what i say is on the abcd it's
about ambulances backlogs care doctors
and dentists i haven't even considered
any other of those sorts of issues i'm
very conscious that people will have
access to the nhs
and
there's nothing more as it were to say
here or we'll see here
okay sorry scotty really good speech
this morning thank you for your time
busy day ahead for you so we'll let you
go thank you thank you